[Music]
so
this girl was sitting next to her very
wealthy husband who felt entitled enough
to talk [ __ ] to lebron james
okay now
i'm the type of [ __ ] lebron got
them both throwing the hell out okay she
was started talking [ __ ] to lebron
she was defending her husband which is
he did not he said i didn't want them to
get thrown out yeah
i mean he said he didn't think that they
should get thrown out
after the fact but he was like yo they
were the ones talking reckless they were
talking crazy now
she alleges that he says some wild [ __ ]
back to her he says shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] is what she said mm-hmm
and low-key coming from someone who's
been heckled
at the comedy shows i've reacted
in a similar way some would say worse
there are some clips we cannot put out
oh man i wish you would
push that button it's ready to go
anytime you're ready the dc one right
no philly billy i heard you talking on
the pod
oh that one was crazy you know that one
i felt that was a waitress right
we could push that button what was it it
was like his wife committed suicide
what was the thing that happened after
you kicked her out you became
a dead wife you were you became a
werewolf halfway through the show
i turned i changed that's what it was it
was
terrifying and know what it is what it
is but it also happened in dc
yeah yeah remember in dc with that one
girl which one
we didn't even make it as part of the
crowd work special because we're all
like everything is good up until here
and then it's too crazy
yeah this is it was wild in dc but she
was a wild girl
and she wasn't stacked with no dsl's
like this girl right here some no lip
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] to me
you got that people have some no lip
[ __ ] coco animation looking [ __ ]
goddamn edward scissor lips
you can't be talking [ __ ] like this get
out of here come on now bro
look like a freshly shaved [ __ ] bruh
you should need that bow you need that
that bad wow
real talk i can't even say what i want
to say because it's incriminating
but you could find anybody's only fans
on reddit
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying you know what i
mean you found al's only fizz
no i paid for it
no but anybody's only fans on reddit you
know what i'm saying let me just say
it's not only fans you know what i mean
there's more
reddit as well yeah basically dove
shared and only fans
from some twinsies oh yeah oh
yeah okay yeah
you would find a way around paying these
hoes
it's such a dumb move ain't it it really
is a dove move
it's on brand as [ __ ] yeah but he busted
out the nudes
from these little chickadees
yes maybe maybe they are maybe they're
not we're not exactly sure and you see
you see vagine from the front you don't
see it open but you see it from the
front
bro bro a little oatmeal cookie sandwich
what you have a little oatmeal cookie
cream pie
i love oatmeal cream debbie hello
down there oh is that what you got a
oatmeal cookie sandwich
is that what you're working with down
there oh
hey i don't know exactly what i'm
talking about
don't you know when you're sitting when
they're looking at you straight
and then you're like oh is there a
little plastic packaging on that because
you got
oatmeal cookies
i don't know why duff would do this i
don't know why doug would do this that's
disrespectful for dove yeah i'm
imagining i said it my way son
that that would be too much you think
surge you think got that plasti
say what did she get the plastic the
snip snip oh you think she got
some sort of surgery on her vagine have
you heard of this
i have okay yeah that's my i have heard
of such a thing you do you think that
that that's
you're saying that you you haven't you
can do whatever you want to the outside
but if the
inside don't feel good i don't know what
you could do to the inside can you make
the inside
snatch can you make the inside yeah
yeah you work on your pelvic floor you
work on your what your pelvic floor you
do kegels
you work on your pelvic floor mm-hmm
fellas why you put an
extra c in there kegels kegels yeah all
i'm trying to say
is i don't know what my girl's been
doing her pelvic floor her ceiling or
the walls but
come on i'd be coming fast lately guys
i come i think i need to be in a colder
time zone
i really do is it a time zone or is it
no it's time it's time i think my
longitudinal attitude is awesome
in the north it's like your dick is
frozen and then it thaws inside and that
gives you a little extra time it's like
a defrost
hole when you're in miami it's good to
go maybe all of our dicks got bigger
because
mine didn't okay
[Laughter]
hey boys we back we in miami shout out
to your pelvic floors
what not all of them got pelvic floors
this lit
you know i mean some of them out here in
the the old wood bro
they might have the old wood you know
it's possible
that they got a little uh what's the
apartment where they got the big
ceilings
some of y'all got a loft yeah some of
you all got a pelvic aloft
is like yo there's some room in here is
this a carport you've got a trundle bed
all right so lebron james yeah
wrong right wrong for kicking this no no
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
whoa bro bro bro yeah bro we in florida
bro that's someone's wife dude yeah
that's original
that was a guy's wife that's his piece
that can't be his website it was his
wife that's why she was barking for so
much she was like you're not gonna talk
[ __ ] about my man low-key he's a
ride-or-die bro
i respect her yeah she gonna get her
husband killed
like those are the type of girls that
get their husband killed yeah because
she got to recognize who
her husband is i will [ __ ] you up it's
like [ __ ]
stop just stop but now you're gonna put
me in a situation where i gotta fight
for you
lebron james what do you want to walk
away from this 70 year old versus lebron
james
i know son that's crazy who do you think
got that in a fair one
if they were shooting a fair one who do
you think got that i'll give it to him
no i give it to the shorty no feisty so
you think she's feisty you think they
start wrestling she just starts sucking
right there
she can take so many punches in the face
bro she got the [ __ ] punches or dicks
no but the punches the lips they almost
got the air bags buffered you got the
airbags it's true
that's true bro you got to look at her
lips they look like an airplane pillow
dude
it's unbelievable i love them you would
wrap it around your neck to take a nap
more than my neck
guys guys i'm engaged yeah that's yeah
you guys are crazy once we got to miami
y'all started acting crazy
you started acting crazy no this
[ __ ] found a way to match a
yankee fitted to a floral shirt i don't
know
how the hell this guy got it in him i
don't know how you know
i'll start playing songs so the point is
we've got a few different people here
that we have to talk about one lebron
james is he wrong for kicking people out
never no honestly he's his venue he's
the franchise it's his venue
he's the reason y'all came to the
[ __ ] thing and decided to almost get
corona in the first place
and if you are talking crazy to him
that's not what you pay the ticket price
for
you're not paying to talk [ __ ] to the
athletes nope what are you paying for
you're paying to watch the [ __ ] game
yeah
kick your ass out if you make them feel
uncomfortable now so the dude
cornball the chick standing up for her
man yeah she's she's dope
i respect it it's she doesn't realize
the cost of that sometimes yeah that's
what i'm saying she's going to get him
into a fight that he's going to have to
take
and he'll get his ass he's going to get
his ass what and he looks like he can
like handle himself so she's gonna get
more bold
she's gonna be a little and she probably
sees a bunch of people being sycophantic
to him yeah and a regular yeah
some rich dude sick of a fan sycophantic
phantom right
you know whoever gave him that hook up
from the courtside seats he ain't
getting it back
you don't think he's getting back he's
paying crazy bread come on dogs
how was he even in there the [ __ ]
stadium was empty that's how rich oh it
was
at the hospital but it's atlanta you're
allowed to have some which is so stupid
because it's
not empty yeah but bro i think they're
allowed doing like partial uh seating
whatever but it's so dumb because if you
really thought that
if you really thought that these people
in the stands could potentially infect
the players
why would you have them close to the
players right you put them in the back
not in the phone it's called court side
literally you're on the side of the
court come on yo and that's where they
got her she took her mask off and it's
like yo you're too close to that thank
god though
yeah thank god yes thank god imagine
that mask trying to hold that thing bro
that's like me trying to talk with the
mask my nose be popping out like what's
going on over here
yeah uh-huh she's here she's like your
nose of lips
say what she has the your nose of lips
can you say this doves
yeah she got the dove's nose of andrew's
nose
[Laughter]
bullying i tried i
um so she's kind of about it she's gonna
get her man in trouble
the thing that i find interesting is
this i asked mark i was like yo can you
find out what her man said
were you able to i couldn't find what he
said okay but i know what she said
now do you know what lebron said back i
looked
i looked this up according to there's an
article this is all according to right
i'm not trying to interrupt
okay but usually if anybody says
anything
in the nba there's a camera angle that
captures it yeah right that's why you
see the players talking with their
jersey over their mouth because they
know they're always being filmed in
there no matter what they say
i find it a little bit a little bit
interesting to say the least that when
lebron
james said allegedly says [ __ ] you [ __ ]
yeah to some lady in the crowd
there's not a single angle of him saying
it yeah
i feel like if this was maybe a six man
on a team maybe some bench player
there might be an angle of him saying
[ __ ] you [ __ ] with some audio yeah
do you think we'll ever see that angle i
don't think it exists
i don't think it exists this is why
she's called courtside karen because
this is what central park karen did is
oh i was being threatened by this man so
you think she's making
she's trying to get out of trouble yeah
oh like the poor that she is
whoa whoa whoa dude dude she's a married
woman yeah that's something she's not
married she's more married than you and
your girlfriend
ain't no hindu ceremony they don't got
no promise rings they don't got nothing
bro you gotta have viewers she's loving
it respectful dog that is some guy's
come dumpster bro you gotta come on
come on can't just be talking crazy dude
you